[Música]
tú cuando te animas se te va a pasar el
arroz te vas a perder lo mejor de la
vida es lo que nos dicen a las mujeres
cuando llegamos a los 30 si no tenemos
hijos y a mí de esas cosas la que me
parece más curiosa es la pregunta y tú
cuando te animas porque para hacer cosas
que me gustan en la vida como por
ejemplo viajar yo no me tengo que animar
ya estoy a dyn animada de entrada
y es que hay algo muy interesante si lo
pensamos bien en la pregunta y es que
nadie quiere tener hijos de manera
automática por eso hay que animarse
cuando pensamos en la maternidad hay un
concepto del que se habla todo el tiempo
y es un concepto que tiene como nombre
instinto y como apellido maternal el
instinto maternal y hablamos de instinto
en dos momentos el momento del antes de
tener al hijo que es aquel que nos
impulsaría a las mujeres a querer
tenerlo y el momento del después que es
aquel que nos impulsa a cuidar a ese
hijo oa esa hija de manera instintiva
una vez ha nacido
los reconoce es verdad es algo muy
popular es una idea de la que se habla
todo el tiempo
pero si os dijera que el llamado
instinto maternal no es en realidad un
instinto
porque un instinto es algo automático
que no se puede modificar y que tiene
que estar presente en todos los miembros
de la especie
si ese instinto que supuestamente nos
impulsa a las mujeres a querer tener
hijos existiera yo cuando cumplí los 14
que es cuando me bajo la regla habría
tenido unas ganas irrefrenables de tener
un hijo y esto no fue así
cuando pensamos en optar por los métodos
anticonceptivos o cuándo
tomamos una decisión sobre si es la
pareja adecuada con la que estamos si la
situación económica es la buena en ese
momento es evidente que no estamos
respondiendo a un instinto sino que
estamos tomando una decisión como seres
racionales que somos una vaca no decide
si quiere tener hijos o no pero las
mujeres sí
por otro lado en el momento de después
de tener al hijo hay una tendencia a
cuidarlo pero es una tendencia no es un
instinto porque los seres humanos no
sabemos cómo cuidar a nuestros hijos una
vez han nacido vamos aprendiendo lo con
el tiempo
lo que sí que se ha descubierto es que
hay una hormona que se llama oxitocina
que aumentan las madres una vez que se
ha tenido al hijo y esta hormona tiene
que ver con el vínculo de cuidar
y lo más interesante es que la una
profesora emérita de la universidad de
california que se llama estará blazer
jardín ha descubierto que esta hormona
la oxitocina no sólo aumentan las madres
sino que aumenta también en el padre en
los abuelos o incluso en los padres
adoptivos entonces porque seguimos
hablando solamente de instinto maternal
hay otro estudio que hizo la universidad
de zanetti en junto con la de sa sex en
el reino unido que investigaba sobre la
identificación del llanto de los bebés
y lo que han descubierto es que la
habilidad para identificar este llanto
no es mayor por parte de la madre que
del padre lo pueden identificar de la
misma manera lo único que importa en
este caso es cuánto tiempo se ha pasado
con ese bebé no el género del progenitor
en definitiva ni queremos tener hijos de
manera instintiva ni sabemos cómo
cuidarlos de manera instintiva y por lo
que dicen los estudios tampoco ese
supuesto instinto sería más maternal que
paternal
entonces el instinto maternal es una
construcción social
esta construcción social que supone el
instinto maternal genera mucha presión
en las mujeres para que nos convirtamos
en madres como os decía al principio se
te va a pasar el arroz cuando te animás
te vas a arrepentir son solo algunas de
las cosas que nos dicen
yo también he recibido esa presión
porque yo no quiero tener hijos incluso
me han llegado a decir que que es pero
yo de la vida si no quiero tener hijos
como si no fuera ya válida por mí misma
como si sólo pudiera ser una mujer o una
persona completa si los tengo
yo de pequeña no jugaba con muñecas no
me gustaba mucho la verdad no sé si
tiene algo que ver o no prefería los
ponies y los libros después fui al
instituto la universidad y durante todo
ese tiempo nunca soñé como algunas de
mis amigas con formar una familia y
tener hijos nunca fue mi aspiración
nunca fue mi proyecto de vida y por eso
algunas personas me han visto como rara
menos mujer infantil egoísta
con una compañera investigue más sobre
este tema y dirigimos un documental que
se llama modern cut sobre las mujeres
que no quieren tener hijos y los mitos
de la maternidad y en el proceso ha
aprendido muchísimo y he reflexionado
también mucho más sobre mi propia
experiencia
como os decía
hay personas que han considerado que no
era normal que yo no quisiera tener
hijos pero resulta que somos muchas más
de lo que parece
según los estudios demográficos entre el
25 y el 30 por ciento de las mujeres
europeas no tendremos hijos y el 10% no
los tendremos por decisión propia
entonces qué ocurre porque parece que
somos tan poquitas es en parte porque
estamos infrarrepresentadas en la
cultura popular prácticamente no
parecemos y en el cine en la literatura
en la publicidad
con estos datos en la mano del 25 30 por
ciento si le diéramos validez a esta
idea del instinto maternal
casi que tres de cada diez mujeres
seríamos algo así como especímenes
fallidos de la especie
yo también lo sería yo también sería un
espécimen fallido pero para hacerlo la
verdad es que soy bastante feliz
no tener hijos me ha permitido hacer
cosas que creo que hubieran sido mucho
más difícil si los hubiera tenido por
ejemplo me puedo cambiar de trabajo y
dejar uno que no me satisface por otro
que me hace más feliz aunque suponga más
inestabilidad económica
también puedo trabajar fuera me ido a
trabajar en el extranjero y sólo tengo
que pactar con mi pareja puedo entrar y
salir cuando quiera duermo super bien
por las noches
en fin que para mí la decisión de no
tener hijos es una gran fuente de
felicidad y de libertad
quizá algunos estáis pensando que es muy
egoísta lo que estoy diciendo es lo que
suelen pensar muchas veces de las
mujeres que no queremos tener hijos
incluso a veces nos lo dicen
pero yo siempre pienso todas las
personas elegimos lo que queremos hacer
en nuestra vida pensando en lo que nos
va a hacer más felices
y por lo tanto las mujeres que no
queremos tener hijos no somos ni más ni
menos egoístas que las que sí que los
tienen
por otra parte no hay ningún peligro la
especie humana no se va a extinguir
porque mujeres como yo decidamos no
tener hijos porque cada día nacen
400.000 personas y somos ya más de 7000
en el planeta o sea que no hay que
preocuparse no es un peligro esto
hay mujeres que tienen tan claro que no
quieren tener hijos que recurren a la
esterilización como un método
anticonceptivo definitivo y cuando van a
pedir esa operación muchas veces los
médicos las tratan con paternalismo las
infantilizan les dicen vas a cambiar de
idea cuando a lo mejor son mujeres de 30
o más años y son muy maduras y muy
adultas incluso a veces hasta les hacen
exámenes psicológicos y yo pregunto cómo
se le puede hacer un examen psicológico
a una persona que no va a traer a nadie
al mundo y por lo tanto su decisión
solamente la afecta a ella misma
otra de las cosas que nos dicen a las
mujeres que no queremos tener hijos es
te arrepentirás te vas a arrepentir y yo
pienso como se atreven a meterse de esa
manera tan directa en la vida de otra
persona en este tema de la maternidad y
no en otros
pues es porque nuestra identidad
femenina está construida alrededor de
tener hijos y si no tenemos hijos es
como si estuviéramos fallando en algo a
la sociedad como si tuviéramos una tara
de todas formas cuando pienso en el
arrepentimiento siempre pienso es mejor
arrepentirse de no haber querido tener
hijos que de sí haberlos tenido porque
de tenerlos estaría afectando a la vida
de otras personas y no solo a la mía
y diréis hay mujeres que se arrepienten
de ser madres sí que las hay
nosotras entrevistamos a sarah fisher
una mujer alemana que escribió un libro
que se llama la mentira de la felicidad
materna
y a ella le han linchado a raíz del
libro en redes sociales y le han dicho
que la van le van a dar una paliza como
la vean por la calle
le han dicho que no se merece a su hija
incluso le han llegado a decir que la
van a matar
y es que inmediatamente cuando una mujer
dice que se arrepiente de la maternidad
la gente piensa que no quiere a sus
hijos y esto no es así sara siempre ha
sabido que quiere a su hija y se ocupa
de ella pero es que se puede querer a
una persona pero arrepentirse de la
maternidad como un rol a cumplir
parece que nos podemos arrepentir de
todo en esta vida de lo único que no nos
podemos arrepentir es de ser madres
todos sabemos que la maternidad no es
una experiencia sin fisuras pero aún así
está socialmente muy idealizada nos
cuentan en el cine en la literatura en
la televisión una historia muy romántica
muy edulcorada como si fuera la guinda
del pastel de la vida de las mujeres
como si no pudiéramos realizarnos de
otra manera que no sea siendo madres
está claro que para algunas mujeres la
maternidad es algo maravilloso pero
muchas otras lo describen como una
experiencia muy cambiante o incluso
durísima y de eso no se nos suele hablar
el embarazo y el parto puede ser algo
precioso para muchas mujeres y para
otras es poco menos que una tortura y lo
mismo pasa con la crianza y es que las
mujeres seguimos soportando la mayor
parte del peso de la crianza según un
estudio reciente que se hizo en españa
el 30 por ciento de las mujeres
abandonan su carrera laboral cuando
tienen hijos
y eso lo que es algo que sólo hacen el
1% de los padres
esta idealización de la maternidad no
solamente afecta a las mujeres que
tienen hijos también afecta a las que no
tenemos porque si la maternidad es algo
tan maravilloso tendrán razón aquellos
que nos dicen que nos vamos a perder lo
mejor de la vida pero yo pregunto es lo
mejor de la vida lo mismo para todas las
personas
para mí un referente en este tema es la
escritora chilena lina meruane a quien
también entrevistamos y estoy de acuerdo
con ella cuando dice que una mujer puede
tener las condiciones físicas ideales
por ejemplo para la gimnasia rítmica y
si entrenara suficiente podría incluso
llegar a ser campeona olímpica pero
quizá ella no quiso hacer eso
y lo mismo ocurre con la maternidad una
mujer puede tener la capacidad biológica
para tener hijos pero si no quiere hacer
eso en su vida no tendría por qué
hacerlo
frases que parecen tan inocentes como tú
cuando te animas se te va a pasar el
arroz te vas a arrepentir son los
ladrillos con lo que se construye la
presión social para que seamos madres
la manera de ser de las mujeres que no
queremos tener hijos es tan válida como
cualquier otra y estamos hartas de que
se nos cuestione por tomar este camino
hay tantas maneras de ser como personas
hay en el planeta y crearíamos un mundo
mucho más feliz si dejáramos que cada
uno y cada una pueda elegir sin
presiones quién es y quién quiere ser
terminaré con algo que también dijo mi
querida lina meruane claro que toda
mujer que quiera tener hijos debería
tenerlos la cuestión es por qué una
mujer que no quiere tener hijos debería
tenerlos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]